يقول المسؤولون العسكريون الأوكرانيون في
منطقة لوغانسك في دمباس ،
إن الروس دخلوا الآن
بلدة تسمى كريمينا التي تقع مباشرة على
خط المواجهة ، وقالوا إنهم كانوا
يحاولون إجلاء الناس ، وهذا أمر
مستحيل الآن لأن القوات الروسية
كانت تطلق النار.  على السيارات المدنية التي
تحاول الفرار ،
يصفون تقارير مروعة جدًا عن قتال من شارع إلى
شارع يدور في تلك المدينة
، والخوف هو أن هذه هي حقًا
الآن بداية نقطة التحول إذا كنت
ترغب في نوع من الهجوم الشامل
على  منطقة دونباس الشرقية
ولكني أريد أن أقول أه إن
القوات الأوكرانية كانت ترد
بقوة على هذا النوع من المثل أه القديم
أن أفضل
دفاع هو في الواقع جريمة
شنوا فيها عددًا من المخالفات
لمحاولة قطع الإمداد الروسي  عندما يبدأون
في محاولة الاستيلاء على أجزاء من منطقة دومباس هذه